one of the best parts of my job is not
only seeing leftists get triggered by
everyday things like men and women's
restrooms but every now and then i get
to be the object of this outrage uh
every now and again and well maybe you
might say like every single day so today
i want to put the anger of trans
youtuber samantha lux and professor dave
on full display apparently i've said
something that they or maybe them or
whatever took issue with let's see what
is this thing doing on the floor that's
we don't have to worry about that we're
gonna read the book now this man has
never met a kid in his whole life never
interacted with one child he's like i
don't give a sit down we're gonna read
the book i'm here for half an hour and
then i gotta go so sit down so i can
film okay
thank you brat
no i think um i think the problem is
that you've never been around a dad
before which maybe i would have already
guessed
um i'm around kids all the time because
i have four of them but so i but i have
by now developed a critical case of dad
syndrome and that means that i'm just
snapping my fingers and i'm keeping
people on task that's what i do i'm dead
you should see me during chore time
every night in my house you get over
there pick up those shoes you come over
vacuum the rug
i don't even remember anybody's names
anymore
that's another symptom of dad syndrome
but johnny's mom's phone said it's not
just pretend
so she went on her phone and there are
people telling her that this isn't
pretend he's really a walrus
only a bigot would say that how dare you
offend what's a bigot anybody know
are i don't even i don't know how all
these kids are i'm not good at
estimating age but they don't know what
you're talking about you don't see their
face
did he run this past like an actual
children's author and we like read it to
a kid and see what they thought before
he published it i think he just went for
it of course they don't know what a
bigot is
they're for i mean it does make sense
that he would go for children because
you know they have the same capacity for
intellectual thought as him like babe if
you're gonna write a children's book
write it for children write it using
words that they understand and that they
know and that you don't have to explain
for them to understand what you're
trying to say through your book
um first of all don't call me babe
second did i run it by an actual
children's author yes i ran it by myself
and when myself came to myself and said
self what do you think of this
children's book idea my self-responded
self that's an exceptional idea
so i did get the go-ahead from an expert
in the field of children's literature if
that matters to you now
sam also says that that some of these
concepts are above a child's head
yes sam
that's the point
now you're getting it if a silly story
about a kid transitioning into a walrus
is inevitably too weird and abstract for
children then what happens if we mix sex
and gender into it
does it suddenly become more appropriate
for children
if a child as you say isn't even old
enough to understand what a bigot is
or to hear the word
then is he old enough to be introduced
to a concept like transgenderism
if he can't understand bigots can he
understand what it means for a boy to
have a girl mystically trapped inside
him
if my book is above his head what about
a choice that will fundamentally change
his life and alter him physically and
biologically forever
is that above his head too
what do you think
connect the dots sam you can do it
our nation's authorities are now openly
admitting to having completely missed
the flashing red lights of inflation in
this administration's failed economic
policy treasury secretary janet yellen
admitted that she was wrong about the
path inflation would take she said quote
there have been unanticipated and large
shocks of the economy that have boosted
energy and food prices and supply
bottlenecks that have affected our
economy badly that at the time i didn't
fully understand didn't fully understand
she says well there you have it straight
from the horse's mouth now i know you're
worried about affording basic
necessities in the months to come food
gas shelter but uh she didn't know it's
not her fault that's the excuse it goes
without saying that you can't trust the
so-called authorities on economic policy
which is why you should invest at least
some of your money in gold and silver
with birch gold group protect your
savings from a highly turbulent economy
economy by diversifying your 401k or ira
into physical gold it's not too late for
you to take action now text walsh to 98
98 98 and get a free info kit on
diversifying and protecting your savings
with precious metals birch gold group
has an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless 5 star reviews
and thousands of satisfied customers
text walsh to 98 98 98 and get real
advice from birch gold today again text
walsh to 98 98 98 to claim your free no
obligation info kit on protecting your
savings with gold
all right those were a few points they
weren't particularly decent or well
thought out but they were points
nevertheless so let's check in with
professor dave
the unfortunate linguistic coincidence
is that we use terms like man and woman
or male and female in describing both of
these phenomena that is where the
confusion arises when people insist that
one term must encapsulate both phenomena
at once
so when someone asks what is a woman
expecting to get a very simple answer
that children can understand they are
sorely mistaken the answer requires a
discussion of genetics and
neurochemistry
well i'm sorry you find it offensive
dave but yes i do deny the concept of
gender as it was conceived by john money
you accept that concept as gospel you're
offended that anybody disagrees with it
um
that's your problem meanwhile you say
that the definition of the word woman is
complicated but please note that
it's complicated is not a definition so
you still haven't defined it i never
insisted on a simple definition i simply
insist on a definition any kind of
definition some sort of meaning you can
give me a complicated one that's fine go
ahead try me give me a complicated
definition i i'm perfectly fine with
that
but you must have some definition
whereas you provide none at all
see this is a major problem for you dave
and let me try to explain why it's a
problem because and listen closely
you are using the word do you see why
that's an issue
you say the word woman is complicated
and apparently ambiguous and hard to
understand
yet you use it
you refer to women you talk about women
i bet you'd even say that you believe in
women's rights would you say that i bet
you would
this must mean that you have some solid
comprehensible idea of what a woman is
yet you never explain that idea that's a
very big problem for you dave you're
using a word that you cannot or will not
define which means either that you're
hopelessly confused and we should
dismiss you and your arguments for that
reason or you're evasive and
disingenuous and we should dismiss you
and your arguments for that reason
either way you and your arguments are in
really bad shape right now now as
promised with the indictment of
conservatives complete i turn to
liberals and the missteps they are
enacting that are preventing resolution
number one please stop saying things
like gender is a social construct
no it is not it is a biological
construct society can't turn you trans
any more than it can turn you gay
gender is determined
biologically
his indictment of conservatives was
complete without ever approaching the
vicinity of any one of our actual
arguments and then he turns to
criticized liberals to prove how fair
and objective he is
by slamming them for not being liberal
enough
he also says that society can't turn you
trans totally ignoring the fact that in
our society currently and only in our
society only in the west there has been
a many-fold increase in trans
identification if that's not society
turning people trans what is it dave
now
i don't know what you'd say to that
because as always and like literally
every other gender ideologue i've ever
spoken to and i guarantee i've spoken
personally to many more people on your
side than you've spoken to on my side
but like all of them you don't attempt
to grapple with any of the logical
inconsistencies of your position but i
ask again anyway if society can't turn
you trans why are we experiencing an
unprecedented skyrocketing rise in trans
identifications if you say that there
have always been this many trans people
but they were all in the closet
you'll then have to explain why there
was never ever at any point ever a mass
epidemic of people committing suicide
because they were not affirmed in their
gender identity after all staple
doctrine on the left is that lack of
affirmation is dangerous because it
causes suicide well then why was that
never happening back when there were
millions and millions of supposed
unaffirmed trans people
indeed why is the suicide epidemic
happening now
when trans people are so affirmed
here's my answer
gender ideology is a modern western
social construct that didn't exist until
it was invented by psychoanalytical
quacks and then parroted mindlessly by
people like you further while pretending
that it affirms and nurtures people it
actually leads them into
self-destruction and despair
the evidence bears that out the evidence
is entirely on my side in fact and not
at all on your side because on this
topic you are wrong about nearly
everything and your underlying claims
are so nonsensical and incoherent that
you can't begin to explain them or
defend them and that's why you don't
even try of course there was a time when
anyone with the first name professor was
thought to possess
superior intellect or at least some kind
of intellect a studious type with you
know thoughts and opinions designed to
shape the world into a better place fast
forward a couple years and that has
devolved into uh professor dave so
before you send your kids off to college
remember that they'll be in the hands of
people like professor dave i don't mean
to end this video on such a scary
thought but it is worth noting